it's my honor to introduce our two
distinguished speakers today
Havas of the maas this tachi america
professor in the School of Engineering
and professor in the Department of
Electrical Engineering at Stanford he is
also the recipient of numerous awards
including the 2016 Richard W Hamming
medal in the 2012 Claude e Shannon award
his research spans several areas
including Network Information Theory
field programmable gate arrays and
digital imaging devices and systems his
research group is currently involved in
projects and smart grids ROM rajagopal
is an assistant professor of civil and
environmental engineering at Stanford
University
associate professor of civil and
environmental engineering at Stanford
University and the founder and director
of the Stanford sustainable systems lab
he specializes in creating and deploying
large sensing systems and using the
generated data together with novel novel
statistical algorithms and stochastic
control to achieve sustainable
transportation energy and infrastructure
networks so with that I'm going to hand
the presentation over to Abbas and wrong
hi um first we're gonna tell you a
little bit about why we decided to offer
this course and then we'll talk about
the course itself and then in the last
part we're going to give you very brief
descriptive of battery systems and their
applications in transportation and grid
services and highlight some of the
content of the course the high-level
motivation for offering this course and
for our research in general is climate
change which is caused by carbon
emissions from burning fossil fuels
transportation electricity generation
contribute the majority of these types
of carbon emissions and high-capacity
battery systems which have been
developed recently are playing a very
important a key role actually in curbing
carbon emissions through electrification
of Transportation
occasion and by addressing the renewable
energy variability so if you look at the
curriculum for battery systems existing
courses such as these ones from Stanford
offer excellent in-depth understanding
of some aspects of battery systems
however because battery systems is
highly interdisciplinary and applied in
nature there is no course that takes a
holistic system oriented approach to
battery system so that's one of the
things that we wanted to accomplish with
this course in addition to the
curricular need there is one more reason
we specifically decided to teach this
class storage systems have been playing
a major role in our research work on the
new grid so here in the figure you can
see the traditional grid structure so we
have generation supplying power to
consumers and power flows from left to
right on this figure in a traditional
grid we don't have storage there for
generation has to meet demand at every
point in time but the grid is changing
significantly in the supply side we're
seeing the adoption of renewables wind
and solar for example as well as the
addition of transmission scale storage
on the consumer side behind a meter
we're seeing the adoption of rooftop TVs
smart appliances and electric vehicles
one kind of important question is how
can we use all of these resources in
order to support the rest of the
ecosystem to do that you need to account
for various considerations first the
fact that if we want to coordinate all
these elements we need to account for
cyber constraints second we need to
account for the Preferences of
humours and third for all the physical
network constraints and this is kind of
has been a key driving question of the
research we have been doing here at
Stanford and one important point is as
we design systems that can do this type
of coordination for evie charging or for
distributed energy resources in homes
and buildings we need realistic and
detailed resource models and as I
mentioned earlier battery storage is an
important resource but any recharging
the battery inside the car is another
resource so since 2016 we have been
doing this project called power net
which is all about how to use the cloud
to coordinate resources in the home it's
a project in partnership with Google
Sonnen the battery systems company
centric drive a motor systems company
and the Navy the project has kind of
four important elements I'll start with
the home hub which is kind of a
intelligence that sits in the home and
communicates to all of the local
resources one of these local resources
is a smart panel that has power
electronics that set in the home and is
designed at Stanford now the home hub
uses its local intelligence to optimize
what the story GV charging solar can do
for the home and accounts for all of the
customer preferences now we may want to
coordinate resources across homes to
achieve goals such as shaving the peak
or automating the response to prices and
in order to do that from the cloud we
have a cloud coordinator which does a
planning step of day in advance so those
are the two kind of main components of
power net but seeing a little bit more
detail what's inside when we are
designing this planning intelligence in
power net we have to come for four major
constraints customer preferences the
network physics meaning the power
network constraints the delays or the
cyber constraint
so in this figure you can see it's
represented as a delay in obtaining data
from the edge of the grid and finally
the fourth one and very important one is
one major resource that we utilize for
cheaper rules is storage and we need
accurate models for storage one for
capturing its aging and incorporating
that as part of the cost and two for
understanding if I send a signal to
storage how it responds and
incorporating that and all the
algorithms as I mentioned before we also
have designed with faculties such as
Professor Juan Rivers who will also be
teaching in our course a power
electronics device smart dimmer fuse
that can be used to control the panel in
your home various types of algorithms
use data generated by all these systems
to make decisions and then they're
building several types of test beds the
first one I want to mention is the power
net lab the SIL lab we have in Stanford
in the white we - building and it
basically has two homes set up in this
lab one of the homes has real appliances
fridges dishwasher air conditioner water
heater a solar panel on the rooftop and
actually battery storage device as you
can see there they're from Tesla in this
particular case and then the other home
has the ability to emulate various loads
both homes are connected to the real
distribution and transmission system and
we have the electronics to do that all
of these homes can be used for
simulating real world conditions and
testing algorithms and hopefully some of
the data from this lab will be available
for our class for students to utilize in
projects together with our initial test
bed we build field tests so right now we
have deployed powernet in a farm you can
see there on the left-hand side on the
bottom picture that gray housing
contains the battery storage that is
used in managing solar power to cool a
barn
where
production is happening so we have seen
tremendous potential for utilizing such
technologies to reducing costs in dairy
farms in another testbed we have
recruited 35 homes here in the Bay Area
that will have solar storage electric
vehicles and people show the power of
coordination in this first project we
saw a lot about how to coordinate the
stationary batteries in the context of
distributed energy resources and
responding to prices and commands but
how about charging so charging is really
about coordinating mobile batteries and
we just started a new project and
program here in Stanford called evey 50
and the goal of this is to figure out
how to coordinate charging particularly
fast charging that generates incredible
demands for the grid and both by using
deferrable charging capabilities as well
as potentially storage and again you
have to account for the potential for
two-way charging the multiple
stakeholders in this coordination
exercise that range from the car
companies the car owner the charging
company and utility as well as various
use cases for example having a fleet of
autonomous vehicles offering
ride-sharing services versus deliveries
versus individual cars to do for doing
all this we definitely mean not just a
detailed model of the grid but a
detailed understanding of the battery
systems so this has been a very strong
motivator for us to teach this course
okay now I wanted to tell you a little
bit about the course itself so the
course provides the system's approach to
studying battery systems rather than and
one of its components so to cover the
various multidisciplinary and real-world
aspects of Bury systems we decided on a
mixture of a seminar and a regular
course so it's a little bit of an hour
unorthodox course in that sense like a
course topics are streamlined so in a
seminar you typically have random set of
lectures about various topics here we
actually try to streamline the the
lecture so that starting from basics and
moving on to real world system
considerations and case studies like a
seminar however we to cover the breadth
of the subject we've lined up an amazing
set of experts in various aspects of
battery systems including academics five
professors from Stanford other than
Raman myself and who from other
universities two experts from National
Labs in rel and Sandia and then experts
from industry Lima Tesla every AV go and
battery design the course when we set it
up it's really intended to mezzanine
level undergraduate and graduate
students in engineering and related
fields as well as engineers
professionals in industry who are
interested in designing battery systems
doing research on battery systems
applying them to transportation and the
grid or just simply learning about
battery systems the course can be taken
as a one unit credit no credit only
seminar in which case the student
doesn't really need to have any
particular prerequisite to take the
class except some kind of
engineering background for example it
can also be taken as a three unit letter
grade only seminar plus a project in
which case we want to make sure that the
student who decides to take it after
looking for a letter grade that the
project that the students is is going to
do is something that he has the
background to do so so that the
prerequisites really has to do with the
project not the course itself for
example if you wanted to do a project
involving electrochemistry or materials
you need to have some background in
electrochemistry a material science in
order for us to say yeah that's a good
match okay so I'm grouping we group the
the topics of the class as follows in
the first roughly speaking in the first
part of the course we're going to talk
about the battery systems themselves so
we're going to talk about the materials
the battery cell for electronics and
battery system management in the second
part of the the course again roughly
speaking we're going to be talking about
some system considerations such as
modeling the gradation thermal
management safety and finally something
about economics of batteries and then in
the third part will be about
applications in electric vehicles and
and the grid there is a detailed
syllabus I believe is posted on the SCPD
webpage which lists the lecture
tentative titles and the speakers so you
can actually see the these topics mapped
to these servers so in remaining part of
the webinar we're going to tell you a
little bit about vary systems and their
applications in transportation and the
great
so the graph on the left here which you
can't see very well unfortunately but it
basically shows that tremendous shows
two things one is that battery systems
are extremely old technology it started
in the nineteenth century and maybe
earlier even the 18th century and over
time and driven by various applications
the energy density which is the what's
our per kilogram have been increasing as
the application needs until and then in
1992 there was a huge jump in energy
density by the development of lithium
ion batteries and these were actually
these were actually driven by a portable
electronic revolution and today there
are 2.7 billion mobile phones that use
lithium-ion batteries the improvements
in battery is not limited only to denser
energy density but also to power density
which here you can see it in terms of
watts per liter or watts per kilogram
and because of these improvements in
addition to the improvement in in energy
density the automotive and grid services
applications became feasible so on the
left here I'm showing a graph which is
the market size for short of the market
that the market size for lithium ion
batteries has been dramatically
increasing and more interestingly the
projection is that the lithium ion
batteries would be a 550 billion dollar
market most of which are for
transportation and for a great storage
now let me tell you a little bit about
batteries themselves so the basic
component of a battery is the battery
cell which consists of an anode a
cathode and a separator in between them
and the self chemistry which is the
choices of materials and chemistry's for
the anode a cathode and the separator
determines the key characteristics of
the battery such as rated voltage energy
density power density and self discharge
rate and and thermal properties and on
the right here you see the basic
packages in which the cells come in
there is a incredibly diverse set of
chemistry's used in with EMI and
batteries and in the class you are going
to hear more about this and about the
how the cells are designed the main
advantages of lithium-ion battery as we
alluded to is high voltage high power
and improved density but lithium-ion
batteries have some important
limitations which have to do with high
sensitivity to overcharging and to the
outside the temperature which affect
capacity and and discharge power but
they also are very important
considerations for safety
another aspect another limitation is
that aging and which is not completely
well understood and again it can lead to
safety issues and you will hear about
these in detail in the class batteries
more than a cell first the batteries are
first up the cells are arranged in
series in parallel
to achieve the voltage and power and
energy
varmint of the application and then the
modules are arranged into the battery
system itself together with power
electronics thermal management
types of mechanical design and these are
all managed using the battery management
system and again we're going to talk
about we're going to talk about this in
detail in the class now let's go into a
couple of applications on battery
systems you want to start with
transportation so 17 million EVs per
year are expected to be sold by 2040
that roughly corresponds to 85% of the
cars in the road
Eevee's present advantages which go
beyond them being green one of them is
that you have a much higher energy
conversion efficiency as compared to
internal combustion engines and they
have lower maintenance costs the
evolution of the lithium-ion batteries
in terms of the power density and energy
density is actually enabling these
electric vehicles to achieve similar
range as what we see today in gasoline
power cars and here we can see kind of a
typical configuration in which kind of
electric vehicles are built this is
called a skateboard platform you can see
the battery system right there and it's
connected to a drivetrain and has power
electronics to manage the charging as
well as the connection to the drivetrain
the battery pack itself is very similar
to what Professor elgamal
showed before except it is going to have
a much more robust thermal and
mechanical management or components and
one of the keys in when you're kind of
designing the bad
system for a car is that you need to
account for specific characteristics
regarding lifespan safety cost
performance and the energy density and
power density needs of the battery
system for a car and this is kind of a
key aspect that we want to bring into
our class another important aspect is
how do we design the battery management
system itself to satisfy the needs of
the automotive applications we are
bringing several speakers from academia
and industry to explain these to us
another important issue for electric
vehicles is how you refuel them or
charging and the increase in level three
charging that's the fastest charging
rates you see out there will result on
dramatic impacts in terms of power in
the grid and unless we figure out ways
to coordinate discharging this will
represent a enormous issue for scaling
the adoption of electric vehicles so we
mentioned earlier the e V 50 project
that we have started a Stanford is
addressing some of that but charging and
its impacts will also be a key aspect
that we will address in the class
finally batteries when they reach about
seventy percent of their capacity due to
aging they need to be recycled and
actually the way that happens is you not
just have recycling you have reused
refabricate and even reselling and so
this whole lifecycle process of the
batteries is something we will have a
lecture on in our course and it's very
critical to the industry now just a
brief overview of battery systems for
the grid and for particularly or for
grid services so grid storage which is
the ability to store electricity now and
use it later has been increasing
dramatically and you can see here in the
figures that lithium ion batteries
correspond to a lion's share
that increase in terms of energy and
power storage is used in many different
places in the grid so in this figure you
can see it's used with generators for
example to support applications such as
outage management directly connected to
the transmission system to participate
in the wholesale markets connected at
the substation to help manage the
distribution network for utility
connected to the secondary transformer
again to help the utilities and finally
customers may own batteries to kind of
do their own demand management or bill
management the location and type of
storage and it determines what
applications it can be used for and we
have as I mentioned earlier various
different types of applications this is
an important aspect of the user storage
and particularly the battery systems for
storage and we will have experts on on
this topic speaking in our course one
specific application we wanted to
highlight is regarding support for
renewable generation so the adoption of
renewables causes significant issues for
the grid on the left-hand side you can
see in dark blue the demand profile here
in California for this summer I picked a
day in the summer and the curve that you
see is called a duct curve which means
there is a significant ramping towards
the end of the afternoon when the Sun
starts to set
we need the increasing adoption of solar
will just exacerbate this issue and if
we add more and more renewables you
might end up with situations like what
is shown on the figure the right hand
side where we have a Texas system with
50 percent renewables and because of the
production of these renewables we expect
a lot of curtailment so it's about 30
that are watt hours of energy for a year
in curtailments due to the variability
that renewables are causing storage
provide
a very good option for addressing both
of these issues first in the duct curve
storage can be used for storing energy
during the hours where the sun is
shining and then using that energy in
later hours of the day eliminating those
ramping issues and second in a grid
where you have significant amount of
renewables just four hours of storage
for example duration can probe can allow
you to recover in this particular Texas
case 28 terawatt-hours of energy and the
capacity of the storage that's needed is
only 14 gigawatts so one key takeaway
from these two studies is that short
duration storage look and so on a lot of
these issues so within a day and battery
systems turn out to be a very attractive
proposition for short duration storage
so here we're seeing the drive and the
predictions in terms of adoption of
battery technology for storage and you
can see it's expected to grow a lot up
to 35 gigawatts by 2030 gigawatt hours
by 2030 when you design battery systems
for storage for the grid you need to
take into account considerations such as
safety cost performance and the lifespan
particularly safety and cost our primary
concerns and you're gonna have experts
in our class talk about the design of
battery systems specifically for storage
applications thank you very much and go
for it so with that I want to turn it
over back over to Abbas and ROM we have
a lot of questions that are coming in I
think the first one to ask that came in
is just to circle back maybe to the
purpose of the course and just again and
you touched on already but developing a
little bit further if you are if someone
is a working professional in particular
area of battery systems what do you
think is the what is the importance of
this course for them and what will they
take away from it
say they're working in materials are
electrical chemistry I think these are
the exactly the type of people we
designed this course for which is to
give kind of an A to Z view of battery
systems and even if you're working on a
very specific area and batteries it
really helps a lot
to put it in context so that you know
how what you're doing affects the
applications and how the and how the
application requirements affect your
work so it's clearly something that will
give you a very broad background on
battery systems that would be extremely
helpful if you're working on even if
you're working on a very specific area
in orem applications of course and with
this apply to say someone who's an
economist or publicly policy expert
who's working in this field as well with
this bring value to their background I
think so we are having speakers who have
those backgrounds as well engineering
economics for example and I think how
this will apply for them is having a
little bit of understanding of what
battery systems technologies are capable
of at what stage of their evolution
they're in and what are the future
potential will help inform a lot of that
work thank you we have a lot of very
specific questions about battery system
so I'm going to jump into those one that
came up a lot are the sort of waste
products of creating batteries and it's
not something that will be addressed in
the course and do you have any comments
or thoughts on that from your own
research I brought in a speaker who will
be speaking specifically about their own
research on this topic of recycle and
reuse what we are also learning on this
topic and it seems to be a key question
for automakers and storage manufacturers
in the world today I think it's it's one
of those topics which is emerging
because store the battery systems are
still relatively new and you don't have
a lot of ones that are not in use
already
before starting to think about what to
do with batteries when the capacity
degrades below a certain percentage like
70% in the case of cars and there are a
lot of ideas emerging so it's not an
established area in which we can have
several speakers it's just it's an
emerging area you're gonna hear about it
towards the end of the class and it
could be an area where somebody would be
interested in a project for example and
it's important to note that one of the
key aspects of recycling or reusing
these batteries is understanding how to
model their aging and so on and that
will be seen in tremendous amount of
detail and the system's understanding in
the course correct may be related to
that or building off that question we
got a few questions about it sounds like
the course is focusing on lithium-ion
batteries our solid state batteries are
they also something that will be touched
on in the course is that also a
technology that you think has promised
in these applications we have probably
not the right people to address the
solid state batteries
however this topic will come up you know
each we and and we'll true from Stanford
we'll be talking about I'm surely gonna
touch on solid state batteries and also
we are working on a panel at the end of
the last class in which we'll talk about
the future of battery systems and I'm
sure that will come up and you may hear
it from other speakers we're not sure
you know who exactly is going to talk
about it so but yes I mean I'm sure it
would come up and and in all ways again
the battery electrochemistry is only one
piece of this puzzle how it fits with
the rest of the system understanding
that in the case of lithium ion will
certainly help you understand what you
need to do when you build those
solid-state batteries as well and
solid-state still uses lithium and
they're still lithium I am so it's not
like it's a different technology it's
just a better way of
instead of the separators of the use now
I've used solid separators which improve
safety but did still livia my own so
will you touch on any other kinds of
storage so there are couple that are
coming up the one that was mentioned a
few times flywheel energy storage and
though we decided so we this is an
excellent question actually because from
the very beginning we decided to focus
on battery systems and more specifically
on lithium you know high capacity
systems in in part because you can't
really cover everything well and as if
you look at the syllabus of the class we
can barely cover the topics on battery
system so it seemed that could be very
very dilutive to to add in more storage
systems but of course these other
storage system are very important that
does not doesn't diminish their
importance it's just that we're not
we're just focusing on on battery
systems and of course that's driven by
transportation and as you have seen
they're still the majority of storage in
in the grid and just to add to that one
of the short classes you mentioned early
on touches upon you know flywheels and
so on and gives a good perspective of
all different types of storage okay so
in terms of the power net project if I
understood correctly it's sort of
looking at the use of energy within the
home do you have other kind of low data
for for other kinds of I guess other
kinds of uses beyond sort of home
appliance use yeah in fact the project
itself is being deployed in the farm
okay that's right so we we have looked
at homes and farms and we are partnering
with some organizations who are
interested in utilizing the same
technology on a building the whole point
of the project has been how to
coordinate storage solar and the
flexible load together in the context of
a power network using the cloud
enter that in the application so yeah it
applies easily to both of their what
kinds of modifications have to happen
between the two I think they apply
generally you have to take into account
the specific characteristics of the
storage you're going to use as well as
the nature of the loads and the models
you might need for those so if I'm
coordinating Eevee storage and solar the
nature of the flexibility of electric
vehicle charging is different than if
I'm trying to manage cooling for example
any thoughts on the capacity constraint
for a grid scale battery installation
what I guess what kinds of capacity in
terms of the grid this this is something
we will address in the class it really
depends on where you are co-located it
if it is with the generator typically is
a couple of megawatts if it is at the
building you know it's gonna be in the
hundreds of kilowatt hours or and if it
is in the transmission system the
largest battery systems might have you
know one hundred megawatt hours or even
more so there you're starting to see
since again an emerging technology and
there's a lot still happening as we
speak does the course focus mainly on
sort of the technology is emerging in
the u.s. does it also look at how its
emerging in other places around the
world not sure there was any folk
geographical focus of the course all the
speakers for logistical reasons coming
from the US so it may have a u.s. bias
but other than that the technology self
of course has no as no geographical
boundaries but but I am assuming that
for example the people for every you're
gonna talk about the Grid applications
are probably going to focus on the US
not outside the US but there's a lot
going on outside the US so hopefully we
don't miss I mean we didn't wanna fly
people from Europe or Japan or China to
you know some of the speaker seems to
have done projects you know worldwide as
was possible and so on but what what the
focus of the class has been is really
this A to Z understanding which was kind
of lacking in our view and if you are
working in terms of a great application
or in the car you may not know all the
details of the battery and how to
incorporate it if you're now designing a
cell you don't know that details about
how the Grid applications work and then
if you're rethinking about the economics
reuse and all of that you want to
understand all of this a lot of this is
actually transferable knowledge it's
gonna be similar in the u.s. it's also
the course also a very important aspect
of the course is talking about issues
that come up in these high-capacity
battery systems in terms of safety for
example which is one of the most
important aspect we have maybe the world
expert on battery system giving a
lecture on that from one of the National
Labs they've been working on this for
about 15 20 years so we're gonna hear
you know thermal issues degradation
issues all of these are people are you
know like the radiation for example
still an area of research so some of the
stuff you're gonna hear about is really
state-of-the-art a lot of it not it's
not just all classical star but some of
it is still open and that's why we
decided to our projects because people
can look at some of these issues and and
and it's worth pointing out kind of the
reason we chose the structure for the
class is that it allowed not just
academics coming in and speaking about
the topic on the cut
of the research but also people who are
building products in the real world for
taking that academic research and
transforming into actual engineered
systems at scale so you're gonna have
both points of view and a little bit
broader understanding of all these
issues and that's what we mean by a
systems approach you look at the whole
thing you don't look at just one aspect
of it and just spend the whole which
which is very important for people
working on such aspect like if you're
designing a cell you do need to take the
classes that talk about the strong
background that for chemistry and
material science so that doesn't take
away from any any of these components if
you are gonna design the part
electronics you need to be an expert in
particular next you cannot just take our
course on design powder economics so but
we wanted to just give people a broad
exposure so that they are they say oh I
see how this affects this and what the
issues are and and what the impact of
certain things will be on other things
that kind of so that's what I mean by
systems and it's very unusual to have
this type of systems oriented classes in
universities in general I mean it's
something that's most the industry does
so we're bringing some of that shall not
be a good segue to just build on the
project itself so a few questions coming
in about that when students enter the
class so they need to have a project a
minor's that's something that can
develop during the quarter we are going
to have a handout in the first week of
the class which contains suggestions for
projects in different areas that we
collected from some of the speakers and
from ourselves and so they are welcome
to choose from these projects we have
ideas of their own that's terrific
it was never tell somebody you know I
write the you know you shouldn't explore
your idea so I think both and then in
terms of the project itself so it sounds
like if you didn't have a background in
power electronics it's unlikely you're
going to do a project in power
electronics so the project will really
build on whatever expertise the student
is building into the class incorporate
in this new broader understanding the
battery system is perfect and of course
you know projects are being done in
groups project groups so somebody in
your group could have the expertise as
well so so there's yeah it could be
interdisciplinary but actually part of
the project proposals there will be a
project proposal first before we say yes
or no and the project proposal we
include in it what's your background you
know why do you think you can actually
do this project right yeah I mean you
know what do you know that that makes
you qualified to embark on this project
it's a you can look at this class is not
a traditional class in which you have a
professor who knows everything and and
then just feeding the information in to
the students this is a community class
you have people coming from different
backgrounds from different things it
bringing different ideas and we're all
gonna learn we're learning as much as
any of the students and that's the
purpose of it it's building a learning
community rather than just a regular
class in which the professor is garden
so everyone so the idea would be
hopefully to get a diverse student body
to bring in a range of expertise to
really build and develop develop and
share that knowledge ensure that
expertise across teams and across and
the project works as an anchor for that
student to go into specific topics that
he may want to learn in more depth
this is now the questions come in but
just out of curiosity why do you think
the system approach is not as common at
academic institutions why is it more of
an industry approach I think it's
because in the university or teaching
people mostly about basics and so it's
very disciplinary approach to teaching
in research on the other hand you have
multidisciplinary research in the
universities of course Peschel Stanford
right but by and large the courses tend
to be very disciplinary and but but I
think we've been talking about this
among each other for a long time is that
we do
to introduce the system approach
it's like product design would be
another example of system approach right
so there are examples of system approach
but it's not that the normal I think in
general when a field is starting out
it's a lot harder to get just kind of
what is the system's approach that's
happening there and it makes it harder
to organize traditional courses but I
think right now what you're seeing is
really a lot of components and a lot of
technologies are mature and the value is
in the system so I'm hoping to see more
and more Shiraz as a facade Thanks so
we're nearing the end I have a few more
sort of battery specifics I may be
coming back to the technology side in
terms of so you talked about the grid
technology talk about the battery
technology I know you also talk about
embedded systems and maybe I'm
interpreting this question incorrectly
but what do you see as the future in
terms of new sensing technology to track
things like the aging of batteries or to
and what are their applications to this
kind of system I think there is some of
the speakers are gonna touch upon those
topics I myself I'm not an expert but
some of the things that I've read about
are things like measuring physical
properties of the batteries such as how
much they expand with heat alone and and
using sensors more inside the cell but
both the new types of sensing that might
happen as well as potentially how to use
it I think those could be great topics
for projects for the course so question
this would be the most interesting
actually one of the most interesting
areas is there's still a need for
sensing in the battery and hopefully
some of the speakers will touch on these
things
well they touch on other aspects so
another question that's come up or
comment is the use of the cars
themselves is it
early regenerative braking but also the
kinetic motion of the cars had something
that also be touched on the way to to
better utilize yeah what's using the
energy to also create energy we're not
really emphasizing the mechanical the
cars do so much in themselves again you
know there are courses that have been
offered before about evey specifically
so we're not talking too much about
power trains and and and and braking and
this kind of thing too much I'm sure it
will come up we have a speaker from
Wymore who will talk about how would you
go about designing various types of
transportation you know how decides the
battery how do you do this and that so
probably he may touch for some of these
things but this is not definitely not
the again we tried to strike a balance
between being broad but not being so
diluted so that's something there's a
certain amount of material it's only
then we you know the quarter is pretty
short and we felt that this is the most
we could do within this ten weeks and
obviously for the course participants
they can always put forward questions to
experts who have designed this bad
reason for a real car something I think
the last question maybe if you can each
touch on what do you see is the most
promising development or new development
in this field if you look at it from
your perspective I think from my
perspective obviously the applications
and what you can do with them it's just
amazing but in order to achieve that in
a massive way we really need to bring
down the cost of these battery systems
that was my generation getting involved
in disease I use these things in
applications and I want to figure out
you know one how to incorporate all of
its characteristics in a better way but
also is there something we can bring
from that side to kind of help in this
cost reduction
I think cost is the most important
okay without bringing I mean if you had
talked to people about batteries six
years ago I'm not using them in the grid
during cars ten years ago or something
you say oh no no no no it's just way too
expensive right
so the technology that in terms of power
density and energy density have gone to
the point where it's actually can enable
a lot of things but the cost stands in
the way and the safety so so I think
safer lower-cost will be the emphasis in
the future not necessarily making power
density higher by a significant amount
or energy density higher by Sigma Gras
so that's basically my so the innovation
is I think you're gonna be mostly in
these areas I don't you could come from
various directions I don't really know
how it's gonna happen okay well thank
you very much for your for your time we
didn't get to all the questions we will
be making a recording of this
presentation available in about a week
and if you're interested in finding out
more information about the class you can
go to either of these two websites and
search for EE 292 X or battery systems
so thank you professors el-gamal and
Roger Gopal thank thank you
you